My intention
has been from the beginning to run,
but there's too many other things
I have to finish in the near term
before I start a campaign.
Is your age part of your own calculation?
Into whether to run again?
No, but it's a legitimate
for people to raise issues about my age.
It's totally legitimate to do that.
And knowing I can say, watch me
a few times.
A man have answered that question.
President Biden
hinting that
the launch of his 2024 reelection
bid could be just around the corner.
So what is First Lady Jill Biden?
Think about that.
Since early
signs travel
with the first lady to Africa
on her recent five day tour addressing
drought and hunger in the region,
she sat down for an exclusive interview.
Arlette Signs joins us now.
So good morning to you.
So is here isn't he
because he says he's got to consult
with the first lady
and you got to ask her. So tell us.
Well done.
Jill Biden,
of course, is a key
figure for President Biden
in so many of his decisions.
And we had a chance to talk
to her about a host of issues,
including that possible reelection bid.
And while she says no
announcement plans
have been finalized, in her mind,
she essentially believes
the decision has been made.
Take a listen.
Your husband was asked in an interview
if he was running
and he joked
that he had to call you to find out.
Was this recently it was resolved
I must have missed it.
So we're going to the source.
Where do things stand
when that one's an announcement coming?
Well, he said he intends to run
So nothing's been planned yet.
I think, you know, he's been so busy with
being in Ukraine
handling some of the crises at home.
So I think, you know,
he's not he's putting that first.
He's putting America's business before.
He's putting his own.
But has
the decision
been made among the family
that he's going to run?
Well, it's
Joe's really it's Joe's decision.
And we support whatever he wants to do.
If he were there,
if he wants to do something else.
Were there too
is there any chance at this point
that he's not going to run
Not in my book.
You're all for it.
I'm all for it, of course.
So as we're reading
all of these tea leaves,
this is just another
indication of the president
is moving closer
to launching a possible reelection bid.
Of course,
his advisers
have pointed to the coming months
as a possible launch date for that.
And you spent time with the first lady
as I said in the introduction to you
as she travels through Africa.
Tell us more about that.
That's interesting.
Yeah, we spent the last five days
traveling through Africa, stops
in Namibia
and Kenya,
where the first lady really talked
about a host of issues,
including women's empowerment,
the importance of young people
and democracy,
and also talking
about some of the government programs
that have aided Africa, including PEPFAR,
which is celebrating its
20th anniversary.
But perhaps
the most poignant moment came yesterday
when she traveled down to rural
a rural village
in Kenya to see firsthand
the impact of drought in the region.
There were hundreds
gathered there to receive health
and nutritional services,
and the first lady got to hear
firsthand what these people
were experiencing.
And as we were there
every step of the way.
And we'll be bringing that to you
a bit later this week.
Oh, interesting.
Thank you very much.
I don't know if you guys have gotten our
like we're going to.
We'll be watching to see that.
But if you've ever gone to Africa
and gotten to see what PEPFAR does, it is
astounding.
It is astounding what
the power of a United States
president, what it what it can do.
By the way,
you can watch the rest of our let's wide
ranging interview.
First Lady Jill Biden, CNN, primetime.
Joe Biden Abroad
airs on Thursday, 9 p.m.,
of course, right here on CNN.
Can't wait to watch that.
And for more on what Joe Biden told
or let there, let's bring in CNN's
chief political correspondent
and the co-anchor of State of the Union,
Dana Bash. Dana.
Anyone who has ever covered
Biden knows that
the probably
biggest influence on his decisions
is the first lady.
So what she says
there carries a lot of weight
about what we could see
happen with his 2024. Right.
So he's definitely running
definitely.
Unless he's not.
First of all, good morning, guys.
Nice to see you.
Not only does she carry
the ultimate weight
but the other thing that you all know
from covering
Joe Biden
for a long time
is that he's not generally
in a rush
to make decisions,
especially big consequential decisions
which is part of the reason
why it's taking as as long
in the view of some Democrats as it is.
I'll tell you
what I'm hearing from sources
in Biden world,
and that is the following.
Just like you just heard
from the first lady,
he's been very focused
on all of the international trips
and and end and policy
that he's needed to focus on as the year
anniversary of Ukraine approached.
And just on the Raw Politics of it,
they insist that because he is not likely
to have a significant primary challenger,
there's no rush to jump in.
They look at the calendar
and the history,
most recent history
of a of a two term president,
and that is his former boss,
Barack Obama, that he didn't announce
until around now.
The thing that is missing
as far as we know,
though,
is the kind of behind the scenes movement
that generally happens or the
the sort of
check out
of the White House
and checking into a political world
from people who are close to him.
We haven't seen that happen yet.
And that is a bit surprising.
Is it
because I feel like he's
taking sort of the diplomatic road
rather than the traditional
I'm going to run for president
because he's using it as,
you know,
traveling to Ukraine and what have you.
And maybe that's his best
bet right now is that,
hey, look,
I'm in charge and I'm leading already
Yeah, that's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
And look, there is frustration
among a lot of Democrats,
especially those who are reluctant
to see him run because really
for one reason only,
and that is because of his age.
And they're thinking, well,
maybe he won't announce.
And if he isn't,
you're leaving
the Democrats
who are going to start
to need to build campaigns
a little bit on in a lurch.
But there's no
real indication,
particularly what we heard,
given what we heard
from the first lady
to our outlet signs that
plans have changed.
You had a really enlightening,
I thought,
eye opening interview
with the RNC chair,
Ronna McDaniel,
after her fourth
win to lead that yesterday.
And this exchange was striking about
whether they will again
call for a loyalty
pledge for the eventual nominee.
Listen,
I want our viewers to hear this
and get your thoughts on the other side.
We haven't put the criteria out,
but I expect a pledge will be part of it.
It was part of 2016.
I think it's kind of a no brainer, right?
If you're going to be on the Republican
National Committee debate, stage
asking voters to support you,
you should say I'm
going to support the voters
and who they choose as the nominee.
I want you to listen to what
former President Donald Trump said
a couple of weeks ago
in an interview
with conservative radio host
Hugh Hewitt on this very topic
If you're
not the
nominee, will you support
whoever the GOP nominee is?
It would depend.
I would
give you the same answer
I gave in 2016 during the debate.
It would have to depend on
who the nominee was.
So are you prepared to block the former
president in 2016?
I did.
Everybody signed it in 2016.
But this is about the here and the now.
He didn't commit to it.
I think they're all going to sign it.
I really do.
She really I remember when she said
to begin the interview,
I ran on a unity platform.
She really sounds like she believes it.
Unity. It's going to be all good.
Everyone on the same page.
What do you think?
I think that is definitely her goal.
I've heard from at least one
potential candidate after that concern
that in her in her effort
to create unity among the candidates
by asking them
forcing them to sign a pledge
in order to get on the debate stage,
it will inherently cause fracture
because of the other thing
that I talked to her about,
which is the elephant,
no pun intended, in the room,
which is the fact
that we're talking about
the former president here,
and we're talking about
a former president
who has
been disqualified
from being president again
in the eyes of several
potential candidates for president.
And the feeling is among some of them,
how can I sign a pledge promising
to support him as a nominee
if he is a nominee?
If I don't think he should be president.
And it's going to be a very tough thing
for some of these candidates
who are going
to have to decide from their perspective
if they are going to put country first
or party first.
And that is kind of the calculus
that is going on.
Not among
all of the Republican candidates
who are not Donald Trump
but among some of them.
Never mind
the question that I put in the clip
that you played
about Trump himself,
whether he will actually stick
to any kind of pledge.
They signed pledges in 2016.
It's not really clear
that they actually lived up to it.
John Kasich
signed that pledge
to get on the debate stage
and he never supported Donald Trump.
Just one example.
Yeah, it's a great point
that it's not just about Trump
and what he does.
It's also what Asa Hutchinson and others.
One fascinating part of this interview,
I thought was where she brought up
the fact that she's Mitt Romney's niece.
Something that we sat down play at times
and she said, I'm Mitt Romney's niece.
I was appointed to the RNC by Trump.
She was
I would support both of them
if they were the nominee,
but I don't know
if they would support each other.
Talking about how damaging
all of this is for Republicans
generally, that they're not
that they don't know for sure that they
support who the nominee is.
Yeah, I really
thought that was interesting.
As well, because she was trying
to make the point that she is a unifier
and she is
somebody who can kind of see broadly
on the entire Republican spectrum.
But look, again, it is damaging
because we're talking about
the influence of one man,
and that is Donald Trump.
If Donald Trump
were not part of this equation
and you're talking about
Ron DeSantis,
Asa Hutchinson, Chris Sununu,
you know, Chris Christie,
name your candidate.
They would all be fine
with signing a loyalty pledge.
This is about Donald Trump
and about the events of January six.
Full stop.